les cigarettiers se sont drapés du
prestige de nos vedettes il a fallu des
décennies pour révéler leurs discours
mensonger où est l'argent qu'ils doivent
aujourd'hui versées aux victimes du
tabac au pays des dizaines de poursuites
contre les géants du tabac totalisent
environ 600 milliards de dollars après
plus de 20 ans seulement deux actions
collectives ont abouti au québec en 2015
ces trois cigarettiers ont été condamnés
à payer 14 milliards de dollars à
environ cent mille personnes atteintes
de maladies liées au tabac les
cigarettiers ont choisi les profits au
détriment de la santé de leurs clients a
conclu le juge une conclusion que n'a
pas entendu le représentant de l'action
décédé avant la fin du procès
aujourd'hui les trois géants affirme ne
pas avoir assez d'argent pour indemniser
les victimes et leurs héritiers elles se
sont placés sous la protection de la loi
sur les arrangements avec les créanciers
depuis trois ans un processus de
médiation est supervisé par le tribunal
mais ce processus n'est pas publique
selon le conseil québécois sur le tabac
et la santé il faudra donc encore
attendre avant de célébrer cette
victoire historique
espérons que ça ne prenne pas encore 20
ans
où